on vous le disait c'est le retour de la
chronique livres elle est avec nous
claudia larochelle bonsoir à vous d'en
soir patrick g t au salon du livre la
semaine dernière et voilà qu'à chaque
vendredi nous allons parler de livres et
vous commencez avec le dernier de cette
romancière joyce carol oates jouer et
romancière américaine fort prolifique
d'ailleurs il y en a un tout le monde
vient juste de débarquer chez moi encore
aujourd'hui donc si ceux-ci
l'avant-dernier l'autre c'est des
nouvelles celui là c'est toujours un
suspense psychologique car très très
bien ça oui carthage donc ça se passe à
carthage dans l'état de new york
c'est le sujet principal c'est à dire
que c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille
qui est retrouvée morte en fait on n'a
pas retrouvé son corps et l'on se
demande qu'est ce qui se passe avec ça
on va suivre le fil de cette enquête là
il ya un homme qui fonctionnait si le
frère c'est le fiancé de sa soeur est
cet homme
l'oeuvre a avoué ses crimes par contre
ce qui est intéressant dire aussi c'est
que c'est un homme qui est accueilli en
héros par ce qu'il a fait la guerre en
irak
on est en 2005 sept ans plus tard donc à
peu près où trois corps du livre il ya
un revirement de situation il ya un
nouveau personnage qui va arriver et qui
va faire chambouler toute l'histoire et
c'est vraiment trépidant parce que elle
maîtrise tellement bien la psychologie
des personnages est fait avec finesse
c'est joyce carol oates j'adore ce
qu'elle fait parce qu'elles maîtrisent
aussi tout l'heure de dresser une espèce
de portraits de la société américaine
le fait avec beaucoup de doigté vous
allez voir on passe à travers les
plusieurs pages là dedans oui en briques
oui on passe très très vite à travers
parce que la faim et les déroutante et
on se dit que ça s'en vient on a hâte
d'aller voir qu'est ce qu'ils sont mais
qui au coni peut-être ce crime là comme
deezer et orange d'énergie pour moi oui
sur fond de guerre d'irak où c'est parce
qu'on parle la guerre d'irak on parle de
ses combattants avec une faille que ça
laisse comme il gagne au oui
nous on ne l'a jamais vu kent nagano
être le maestro nagano à être très
réservé un peu pudique qui se dévoile
pas beaucoup et cette fois ci est la
donnée ces confessions à indique l'ofs
c'est paru chez boréal et d'entonner
merveille ce qu'il dit c'est un
véritable plaidoyer pour l'amuser pour
l'importance de la musique classique et
il sonne l'alarmé c'est ça qui est
intéressant de venir porter faut faire
attention parce que tous les orchestres
dans le monde sont un peu ils y ont des
troubles
les jeunes ne sont pas au rendez-vous et
justin exprès comme ça tout au tout
rapidement le public vieillit il
grisonne comme moi toujours plus d'année
en année et cela m'inquiète
autant que la baisse constante du nombre
d orchestre où sont les jeunes gens de
20 ou 30 ans ce qui remplissait les
salles de concert il ya tout juste
quelques décennies il ya un problème il
met le doigt là dessus à travers tout ce
qu'il fait c'est qu'il parle aussi de
son enfance comment la musique et harvey
dans sa vie on allait dans les années 50
l'héritage aussi laissé par ses parents
et on part de là qu on parle de la côte
ouest américaine aussi donc si racines
les grands mentor de sa vie les grands
musiciens aussi come back qui ont
façonné sa manière à lui interprété la
musique de faire un musée alors si des
propos brillant les propos oui qui sonne
sonne l'alarmé en quelque sorte il parle
de cette importance de la musique dans
nos vies et dans celle des nouvelles
générations aussi faut pas l'oublier
y'avait pas si longtemps ces matinées
symphoniques toutes les écoles à peu
près elle est là c'est de plus en plus
rares et voilà et c'est très intéressant
oui passionnant et qui justement parle
berti pour les petits justement la
relève ça ne nous rajeunit pas patrice
la guerre des tuques on regardait la
guerre des tuques on a vu un film en 84
d'andré melançon
hélas cette fois il ya eu la guerre des
tuques 3d on est dans la foulée la
sortie de ce film là est l'un des albums
qui paraissent chez bayard et en profite
pour remettre ce film-là sur la map à
travers des albums jeunesse dont celui
là la guerre la guerre ce pas une raison
pour se faire mal
phrase culte de la guerre des tuques et
si tu prends une belle synthèse ce qu'on
retrouve dans l'esprit de ce film
on retrouve tigi la lune daniel
blanchette de victoriaville tous les
personnages prochain oui c'est très
mignon c'est pour les enfants puis en
même temps pour nous ça nous rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs
les lectures dit ça nous rajeunit pas
moi je vais vieillir encore plus ce mois
ci plus c'est plus la guerre des boutons
le film français après 102,1 oui ou le
petit gars disaient si j'avais su
j'aurais pas venu puis jouer à se faire
mal aussi un peu de livres en quarts
elle pas eu de l'hypnose et la rocha
merci beaucoup d'un plaisir la semaine
prochaine taxe est ma patrie